Let's see. How do we want to do this?
Now, I'm looking at the side opposite this 42 degree angle.
And I'm going to be comparing it to my known side of the 1000 meters.
You also could've compared it to the x, but I'm going to do it this way.
So, opposite and hypotenuse--it looks like I'm going to need sine. Okay.
So sine of 42 degrees I know that equals 0.669.
But I also know that it must equal the opposite over the hypotenuse.
That's what the sine is and that equals y over 1000.
Now, I can multiply both sides by 1000 just like I did before
to get that y = 669 meters.  Pretty cool.
Now we're really getting to the point where we can start to calculate the circumference of the earth.
Before we move any further, there's one more tool I think we should learn.